who was 15 when she left the UK to join
Islamic state has had her bid to
overturn that decision to strip her of
her British citizenship that's failed so
she can't return to the UK what do you
make of that decision look I welcome the
Court's decision uh but you'll
understand I can't uh comment more
because there are legal considerations
ongoing I just welcome the fact that the
government has and always will take all
actions necessary to defend the British
people so you welcome the decision you
think it was the right decision look I
welcome the decision I'm afraid for
legal considerations I can't say anymore
how close is a brexit deal
well the talks are ongoing they're
positive sort of underlying and the
Prime Minister both said that they are
positive and the Prime Minister has been
in Northern Ireland recently and has
been speaking to colleagues across
parliament in recent days as well
because this is a decision not just for
Northern Ireland but for the whole of
the United Kingdom
it's not going to happen is it I'm very
confident the Prime Minister will get
the best deal possible for the country
and that's exactly what he wants that's
by the way also what the T-shirt wants
in Dublin it's also what the president
of the European commission wants in
Brussels I guess the issue is it's not
just about getting the best deal or what
the Prime Minister thinks is the best
deal and I can't comment on that right
because I haven't seen the deal I don't
know how good it is or not but it's
about politics as well isn't it and
what's become abundantly clear is that
the PM hasn't squared off the people he
needs to in order to get this brexit
deal through the dup the Euro Skeptics
in your own party well look I think this
is part of the negotiation right I mean
because the negotiation with the
European Union is about making sure that
we get the best deal with the European
Union and that we get the best
partnership with the Republic of Ireland
going forward and yes of course it means
listening to all voices across the
United Kingdom but it means listening to
all voices in the conservative party of
course it does but across the United
Kingdom means also the communities in
Northern Ireland and that's why the
Prime Minister has invested so much time
so much effort talking to our partners
not just in the dup but in the earth to
unionists and the other parties in
Northern Ireland it doesn't look like
it's paying off though the dep they are
absolutely critical as you and I both
know and I've used them as well to
getting a brexit deal across the line I
just want to play you what Jeffrey
Dalton of the dep said at Prime
Minister's questions today let's listen
and will he assure me that he will
address these fundamental constitutional
issues and do so not just by tweaking
the protocol but by rewriting the
legally binding treaty text
rewriting the legally binding treaty
text it's not going to happen is it well
the prime minister's answer to that
question was very interesting because he
was entirely complimentary of Jeffrey
and Jeffrey has been somebody who many
of us worked with for a long time in
fact I was in the army with Jeffrey's
brother they've been friends for a very
very long time this isn't very important
negotiation it's a very very important
deal and for those of us who are
absolutely passionate conservatives of
course yes but unionists as well
recognizing that the whole of the United
Kingdom needs to be kept whole and
integral in the single Market in the
internal Market of the United Kingdom
recognizing the the both communities and
protecting the goodness all the
specifics of what Jeffrey Dalton is
saying right and I get that the tone is
very measured but you have to listen to
the substance not the tone and the tone
he is saying is he wants it Rewritten
the text Rewritten and that's not what
the EU is going to do well what he wants
is he wants an agreement that keeps the
internal Market of the United States he
was very specific about what he wanted
he wants to be reopened he wants the
internal Market of the United Kingdom
held together of course he does he's so
do I by the way he wants to make sure
that the United Kingdom is whole and
integral of course so do I but he also
wants to get over uh the difficulties
that the protocol has been causing at
the moment and he's not alone in that
other parties in Northern Ireland other
parties in the Republic of Ireland and
other parties in the European Union have
also spoken about resolving the
difficulties so I think this is a really
good start for a positive series of
conversations no we're not at a deal yet
that's true but that's exactly what
we're working towards and to have Ursula
vandaline and the Prime Minister saying
positive things I think that's a good
start well you've got the EU and the
Prime Minister saying positive things
but the problem is that people back home
we need to vote for the deal the dep
have got serious red lines and it looks
very hard to clear and of course people
in your own party as well the Euro
Skeptics too have been expressing uh
concern about the deal it does feel like
you know know anyone could have
predicted that this was going to happen
anyone paying any attention to the last
five years of Westminster could have
predicted this was going to happen
Sophie it's it's certainly true that
nobody is going to be surprised that
there is a lot of discussion about it
that's discussions one way of putting I
mean that's how discussions work I mean
there's a lot of discussion about it
that's absolutely right and the prime
minister is in the process of having
those discussions now what we've got to
do is get to a position that works for
both communities in Northern Ireland
that's absolutely essential and that
maintains those those essential points
it maintains uh it protects the Good
Friday agreement it keeps the internal
Market of the United Kingdom uh solid
and and and and open and of course it
resolves the difficulty that so many
different people are talking about today
you don't have to be Jeffrey Donaldson
you can you can be Doug Beatty who leads
deals to unionists and indeed other
members of different parties in Northern
Ireland who all talking about this need
to resolve some of those problems so
that's not a that's not a unionist
position it's not nationalist position
everybody's talking about it I just
wanted to listen to what Steve Baker had
to say to me it was a weekend before
Rishi sunak effectively won the
leadership contest he was backing Rishi
sunak but he did so with a very clear
Red Line some would say you know he was
always laying down the law let's have a
listen to what he told me that this is
what Steve Baker said the current policy
on the Northern Ireland protocol must be
continued and I think this is another
absolutely crucial point if if say Rishi
doesn't or Penny didn't carry through
that policy the Euro Skeptics would
implode the government and again
whatever anyone else may think that my
colleagues like friends like Bill cash
and Mark Francois and John Redwood they
are not going to tolerate any diversion
any equivocation on this point
he's right isn't it the Euro skeptic is
about to employ the government Steve is
a great guy and a good friend and a man
of very high integrity and he is now in
the Northern Ireland office part of
these talks so frankly if we can get
does he support it Steve's part of the
talk Steve is actually in the Northern
Ireland office part of these talks so
Steve will no doubt be making sure that
his voice is heard and the voice of
those people who like him have been on
the eurosceptic wing of the party are
heard and that's really important it's
absolutely fantastic that we've got
somebody like Steve making those points
inside government so that when we come
to having those discussions outside
government with the rest of the party as
you quite rightly say the voices have
not just been heard at the end but
actually right through the process so I
think it's very positive can you say for
sure there will be votes on this look
the Prime Minister has said today that
Parliament will have his voice heard and
there are many different ways in which
the Parliament can happen does that mean
there will be a vote on any brexit deal
you'll have to ask the chief whip about
that I'm afraid the chief whips in
childhood parliamentary business but the
Prime Minister has been extremely clear
that the parliament will have its its
voice heard and in many ways we're
having our voice heard at the moment of
discussions are being conducted and
we'll we'll have to see what happens in
the end doesn't sound like a yes to me
well you'll have to talk to Chief whip
I'm afraid I don't understand you said
the PM's being clear exactly tell me
it's very clear the parliament's having
its voice heard isn't it is it yes what
so will that be a vote but Parliament
has its voice heard at the moment this
is the the discussions that we're having
but that's the point isn't it if you say
that parliament's having this voice
heard now then it's meaningless doesn't
mean that there's gonna be a vague does
it so I'm not gonna I'm not going to
tell you what the what the votes are or
not going to be okay you campaign to
remain uh of course in the EU has brexit
been a success this is the decision the
British people have taken the decision
and what we've got to do is make sure
that it works and the challenge that
we've got at the moment is to make sure
that we resolve those issues in Northern
Ireland in Northern Ireland there are
some very very particular issues you
know them you've covered Northern
Ireland for a lot longer uh than I have
in some ways and and it's absolutely
essential we focus on what those
challenges are and we resolve them
because the Good Friday agreement that
we're celebrating 25 years of this year
was a remarkable achievement by some
outstanding people who managed to get
round the table and resolve a problem
that would mean ongoing for nearly 100
years and to see people like Seamus
Malin David Hume and David Trimble
getting around that table and actually
making this peace process work giving us
25 years of Peace not just in Northern
Ireland but in London and indeed in Kent
where that deal bomb killed so many
Royal Marines reminds us why this isn't
just about Northern Ireland it's about
the whole of the United Kingdom are you
a bit worried about are you talking very
eloquently about the Good Friday
agreement and about the history in
Northern Ireland are you worried that
it's at stake no I'm very positive that
actually what we've got ourselves into
is a situation where these discussions
these conversations are being held
peacefully by elected members not by
gunmen not by militias but by elected
members of various different parties
across our islands and I think that's
really important
um I want to talk to you a bit about
Ukraine if I may and President Biden the
U.S president visited Ukraine uh
recently our significant moment was that
I think it's a very significant moment I
think it's it's quite noticeable that a
U.S president has gone
to a war zone um I can't think of an
occasion when a U.S president has done
that other than to go and visit U.S
troops so it's uh certainly not in
recent uh not in recent years so I think
it's it's it's pretty telling and I
think it speaks to the extraordinary
courage of President zielinski and to
the importance of the Ukrainian people
and the the fight that they are
conducting because they really are quite
literally on the front line of freedom
and we know absolutely that Putin's
Ambitions would not stop in Ukraine were
he to be let through and therefore what
they're doing is they're defending us
all what do you mean by that that his
Ambitions wouldn't stop in Ukraine well
let's let's just have a look at the last
20 years
um if you if you go to 2007 for example
you see a very major Cyber attack on
Estonia in 2008 you see the invasion of
Georgia uh in 2000 and I think it was 11
or 12 forgive me I'm going to get it
wrong but a Ukraine an Estonian Border
guard was kidnapped from the Estonian
border and taken to Moscow put on trial
you see later incidents in Ukraine
whether in 2014 of course the invasion
and the capture of Crimea later attacks
in Montenegro attempted assassinations
attacks in the Czech Republic and indeed
here in the UK the use of a chemical and
a nuclear substance to murder
individuals here in the United Kingdom
now those some of them weren't acts of
War but all of them were warlike acts
and here we are seeing a genuine Act of
War a major element of State aggression
the kind of which we haven't seen in 80
or so years so you say that Ukraine is
on the front line for freedom and of
course I live this month presence Lansky
came here to the UK speaking to MPS I
think was the second time he'd left the
country since the invasion and he had
one really clear message he said that we
need Jets is he going to get them well
we've already started training Ukrainian
partners and I have to say I think
that's an incredibly important thing to
do because what you don't want to do is
make the decision then find you've got
six months to wait until you've trained
the people uh to operate the machine the
equipment so I think that's a really
really important decision but let's not
undersell what we're already doing since
2014 the United Kingdom has been
training the Ukrainian Armed Forces
we've been assisting with any number of
different forms of intelligence and
sorry cyber support in terms of the
Cyber defense of Ukraine and we've been
making sure that the Ukrainian people
are in the best possible situation I
think anyone would dispute what the UK
has done to this point but the question
specifically about Jets and I honestly
don't really know what the answer is I
can't work out if you're saying yeah
it's on the table because yes we're
definitely going to do it or actually
we're just kick it into the long grass
that's not going to happen what is it
are we going to give Jets that's not a
decision we're going to take right now
that's a decision that we're gonna have
to consider but of course what we've
already done and this is why I think the
prime minister's decision to begin
training is so important is we've
already put the ukrainians in a position
where were that decision on Jets to
change they will be in a position to
accept them we have potentially
um opened the door to giving Jets to
Ukraine we're also sending 14 tanks I
think are we going to backfill them in
our own Army I'm afraid you'll have to
ask the defense secretary about that and
that's going to come up in the
integrated review so I'm not going to
preempt that sure and should there be
more money for defense in the budget 11
billion pounds
so look I'm I'm an ex-soldier you're
never going to hear me say no to that
question but but the reality is there's
a huge number of things we've got to
balance uh at the moment this has been a
really difficult time for the country
you don't need to tell you that you've
been covering it in great detail and
what we've got to do is we've got to
make sure we get a first settlement for
everybody in the United Kingdom but also
that we keep ourselves safe okay thank
you very much thank you